Trascrizione: Angelica Spigoni
Revisore: Federico MINELLE
(Musica)
La nostra civiltà,
la nostra civiltà tecnologica,
si basa su degli strumenti.
Questi sono quelli che abbiamo iniziato
a sviluppare millenni fa.
Erano pietre, martelli, armi.
Erano oggetti fisici, inizialmente,
e poi si sono evoluti.
Ci hanno aiutato ad essere più veloci,
dove eravamo lenti,
di essere più forti,
dove ci mancava la forza,
si può dire che quello che abbiamo adesso
è grazie a questi strumenti
che abbiamo potuto inventare.
In fondo ci hanno consentito
di vivere meglio.
Vorremmo che migliorassero sempre per
supportare la nostra qualità della vita.
Vorremmo che questo trend continuasse
e magari che fosse continuo
in maniera esponenziale.
Il motivo per cui questo è successo
lo dobbiamo solo al nostro cervello.
Proprio ultimamente, negli ultimi 15 anni,
si sono individuate
le aree del nostro cervello
che controllano l'uso degli strumenti,
oppure li riconoscono,
oppure capiscono la loro funzione.
Tutto questo è molto importante perché poi
su questi strumenti abbiamo basato
la nostra tecnologia.
Una cosa che vorremmo
è che questi strumenti fossero fisici.
Molti lo sono già.
Se uso un martello
certamente è uno strumento fisico,
ma lo devo usare io.
Altri strumenti sono un po' meno fisici.
Il calcolatore è uno di questi.
Certo posso fare delle cose,
certamente ho dei risultati,
ma in quanto ad agire nel mondo,
il calcolatore non fa tantissimo.
Quello che ci serve è dotare
la tecnologia dell'informazione
di un corpo.
Come indicato in questa immagine.
L'idea è che io possa chiedere
ai miei strumenti di fare qualcosa.
Se io oggi chiedo al mio smartphone
di fare qualcosa di intangibile,
notifica dell'informazione,
cambia qualcosa,
ma a meno che non ci sia alla fine
qualcuno che agisca per me,
non riesco a muovere degli oggetti,
per esempio.
Invece quello che ci piacerebbe fare
è che la tecnologia dell'informazione
si connettesse al mondo reale, fisico.
Questo è stato illustrato
tante volte nel cinema.
La robotica si è vista spesso
in vesti più o meno carine.
Qui ho preso solo le vesti carine,
quelle più simpatiche.
La possibilità di avere
l'inserviente robotizzato,
piuttosto che l'aiutante o il compagno,
o robot che aiuta la persona più debole,
in questo caso c'è un film recente,
abbastanza conosciuto,
dove il robot aiutava un signore anziano.
Questo ovviamente è il cinema.
Noi vorremmo che questa cosa
si connettesse alla realtà.
Da un certo punto di vista,
abbiamo la tecnologia dell'informazione
che si connette al mondo fisico.
Dall'altro punto di vista, la fantasia.
Ci siamo sempre immaginati queste cose,
vorremmo che si connettessero alla realtà.
Come si può fare? Come vorremmo farlo?
La nostra scommessa è che questa cosa
si faccia con la robotica,
con tipo particolare di robotica,
che ha sembianze umanoidi.
Questo è quello che è indicato qui.
Questo non è un film.
La foto che vedete non è presa da un film,
è quello che facciamo tutti i giorni.
Questa è la nostra ricerca
nel campo della robotica umanoide.
Vorremmo dare un corpo
alla tecnologia dell'informazione.
Immaginate poter avere una macchina
a cui chiedete, banalmente,
di portarvi il caffè,
di trovare delle cose per voi,
però di farlo per davvero.
Non è come il cellulare.
Io posso usare il mio smartphone
e chiedere:
"Chi è il Presidente
del Consiglio italiano?"
E lui risponde, esiste un'app per Android,
per esempio, mi risponde e dice chi è.
Mi trova una pagina web,
compare la pagina con la biografia
con le informazioni connesse
a ciò che ho richiesto.
E questo è fattibile.
Però se chiedo al mio smartphone
di portare un caffè, non c'è verso.
Ora, vorremmo che invece questo
diventasse possibile.
Questo è ovviamente un esempio banale,
ma immaginate le applicazioni
se potessimo cambiare
i nostri dispositivi in questo modo.
Potrei averlo detto io, ma voi direste:
"Giorgio Metta è un pazzo,
venuto qui a raccontarci queste cose".
Però ci sono degli altri signori
che hanno detto cose simili.
Uno sicuramente è Bill Gates.
Nel 2008 scrisse un articolo
per Scientific American,
dove diceva che il mondo sarebbe
molto interessante
se si riuscisse a mettere
un robot in ogni casa.
Cosa voleva dire lui?
In effetti,
siamo all'inizio di una tecnologia
che potrebbe essere messa in ogni casa.
Bill Gates faceva un confronto tra
la tecnologia dell'informazione iniziale,
quando scriveva i primi sistemi operativi,
con la situazione adesso della robotica.
Siamo comunque agli inizi,
c'è ancora della strada da fare,
ma le potenzialità ci sono tutte.
A conclusione dell'articolo, diceva anche
che una eventuale ditta,
che vendesse robot da utilizzare in casa,
diventerebbe sicuramente molto più grande
come dimensione, come fatturato,
di Microsoft stessa.
Perché avrebbe qualcosina in più,
la connessione col mondo fisico, reale.
Un altro signore che dice cose simili
si chiama Rodney Brooks.
Ѐ il signore che vi ha messo in casa
il Roomba.
Se non l'avete, però almeno
sapete cos'è:
è un primo robot di successo
con distribuzione consumer.
Qualcosa che è andato al di là
dei pochi esemplari costruiti.
Adesso questo signore si è
imbarcato in un'altra avventura,
ha lasciato IRobot, la azienda
che faceva i Roomba,
e si è messo a fare qualcos'altro,
che sono dei robot, più o meno umanoidi,
per l'industria.
Sono robot con due braccia,
con delle pinze un po' particolari,
e hanno la bellezza, se volete,
di essere programmabili in modo semplice.
Lui ha preso veramente gli operatori
della catena di montaggio,
e ha detto: "Vi dò questo robot,
voi in 10 minuti lo programmate,
gli fate fare il vostro compito,
e voi state lì a guardare."
Questa qui era un po' l'idea
di questo nuovo progetto.
Tutto sommato credo che sia interessante.
Poi dice anche: "Gli uccelli del
malaugurio vedono sempre male,
adesso dicono
che tolgo i posti di lavoro."
Quello che dice è: i task ripetitivi
non sono divertenti per nessuno,
se ce ne liberiamo forse è meglio.
Le persone, dopo, forse diventeranno
programmatori di questi nuovi robot.
La nostra esperienza, la nostra bravura,
sarà non tanto nel ripetere azioni a mano,
magari mettere le cose dentro le scatole,
ma esisterà un robot
che fa lo stesso lavoro,
e io devo programmarlo.
Di giorno in giorno potrà cambiare
leggermente il compito,
e io potrò essere sempre la persona
che in realtà programma il robot."
Ci sono altri signori, ancora, in questo
caso intervengono le istituzioni,
o la politica, che dicono che
dovremmo fare queste cose.
In particolare, la Commissione Europea
ha identificato una serie di obiettivi
nel prossimo programma quadro.
Alcuni li vedete qua, sono potenzialmente
attaccabli, o se volete,
la robotica può fare una parte da leone
all'interno di questi obiettivi.
Uno è contrastare, o in qualche modo,
far fronte al fatto
che la popolazione invecchia
progressivamente.
Da qui al 2020, il numero di anziani
sarà salito del doppio rispetto adesso.
I numeri sono più o meno questi qui.
Ѐ necessario essere comunque produttivi,
in maniera sostenibile.
Per questo l'automazione può fare
una parte molto importante.
Ci sono problemi,
come il riscaldamento globale,
che possono essere, sicuramente,
non risolti, ma monitorati,
attraverso soluzioni robotiche.
Esistono robot per il
monitoraggio ambientale,
questi potrebbero ricoprire
un ruolo importante.
E poi nella sicurezza.
Tutti si ricordano il disastro
nel Golfo del Messico o Fukushima.
Anche in quel campo, avere dei robot
potrebbe diventare una soluzione.
Quindi, vedete, ci sono vari predicatori:
Bill Gates, Rodney Brooks, le istituzioni
stanno dicendo la stessa cosa.
Quindi, s'ha da fare.
In particolare, vorrei adesso dirvi
che cosa dobbiamo fare.
Perché insomma, è bello dire
"Facciamo dei robot",
ma poi bisogna farli per davvero.
Questo è quello che abbiamo fatto noi,
questa è la ricerca che stiamo
portando avanti.
Ѐ un robot umanoide,
come avete visto dalle foto prima,
prima che iniziassimo il progetto
questo qui non esisteva.
L'anno prossimo compiamo 10 anni di vita
stando dietro a questo oggetto qui.
La particolarità, se volete, del progetto,
è che è completamente open-source,
per cui in teoria chiunque lo può
copiare e riutilizzare.
In pratica non è tanto semplice
copiarlo e rifarlo,
anche se prendete i disegni non potete
ricostruirlo in cantina,
però in linea teorica potete guardare
come è fatto il software,
potete guardare le soluzioni
che abbiamo adottato noi,
e questo dà una mano a costruire
una comunità della ricerca.
Quindi, quei pallini che vedete
nella mappa del mondo,
sono posti dove abbiamo il nostro robot.
Vedete, in Europa è stato facile,
ce ne sono tanti, grazie anche
al supporto della Commissione Europea,
e che i colleghi ci conoscono meglio.
Però, vedete che c'è anche
un pallino sul Giappone.
Questo non è male per un robot italiano,
perché mettere un robot in Giappone
tutto sommato è motivo di orgoglio,
quindi per una volta possiamo dire
che abbiamo esportato qualcosa.
Ce ne sarà un altro in Corea
l'anno prossimo,
che è già indicato
perché è in fase di costruzione,
e ce ne è uno anche negli Stati Uniti.
Gli Stati Uniti sono un po' più ostici
da questo punto di vista,
perché cose che non sono fabbricate lì,
si fa un po' più di fatica a venderle.
Ѐ andata talmente bene che l'anno scorso
ci hanno anche confuso per tedeschi.
Esisteva questa foto, Angela Merkel
con il nostro robot ad un evento,
il Financial Times parlando della Germania
ha scritto un articolo intitolato
"La macchina miracolosa"
e hanno messo una macchina,
un robot umanoide in questo caso,
e in qualche modo
hanno connesso le due cose.
Peccato che il robot fosse italiano,
il Corriere della Sera
l'ha visto e ha fatto un altro articolo,
dicendo "Elogiano la Germania,
l'economia tedesca va benissimo,
però il robot non era tedesco".
Tutto sommato, motivo di soddisfazione.
Il robot è anche apparso in una
serie di riviste, badate bene,
questa non è scienza, sono solo
cose giornalistiche,
ma fa piacere vedere
che il pubblico è interessato a vedere
come sta andando la robotica.
Con questo video vi faccio vedere
cosa fa il robot.
Il video è una composizione
di tante piccole cose,
ma dà un'idea delle capacità.
Per esempio, dà un'idea che
il robot abbia gli occhi per vedere,
ha le mani molto sofisticate,
si riconnette a quello che dicevo
all'inizio sull'utilizzo degli strumenti.
Se dobbiamo avere degli strumenti,
ci vogliono le mani per poterli utilizzare
e questo robot ha le mani,
cosa diversa da ciò che
si trova di solito in commercio.
Vedete che può vedere le cose,
gli si può chiedere di indicare le cose,
quindi riconosce gli oggetti
che si trova davanti,
qui ad esempio gli si chiede,
qual'è la pallina rossa tra tutto
ciò che trovi sul tavolo, e lui la punta.
Questa è una serie di potenziali
funzioni, può toccare le cose,
gli si può chiedere di prenderle,
nella prossima sequenza
afferra un oggetto.
Questo è un inizio per avere
uno strumento che vi fa il caffè.
Questo è l'oggetto che vi serve per:
"Prendi il caffè, prendi la tazzina,
metti questo qua, sistema".
Insomma, potete immaginare cosa può fare.
Qui è un esempio dove
il robot guarda qualcosa,
acquisisce informazioni sulla forma
e sulla consistenza di un oggetto.
Per ora sono solo giocattoli,
ma si può modificare facilmente
per utilizzare altre cose.
E questa è un'altra cosa simpatica,
al robot viene insegnata un'azione nuova.
Questa è una cosa che il robot
non aveva mai visto,
rovesciare qualcosa dentro un contenitore.
Gli viene insegnato prendendolo
e muovendolo lungo una certa traiettoria.
Lui sente quanta forza è stata impressa,
memorizza la traiettoria,
ed è in grado di ripeterla per portare
a compimento un certo task.
Un ulteriore elemento
per poter fare queste cose
è avere il supporto dei centri di ricerca,
delle istituzioni, dello Stato.
Qui volevo raccontare che è
necessario fare anche dell'altro,
bisogna investire nella ricerca.
Ѐ abbastanza scontato da dire,
lo dicono in tanti,
ma poi farlo è complicato,
soprattutto in periodi di crisi economica.
Però questo è il tipo di ricerca
che vi potrà far avere il caffè a letto
senza doverlo chiedere a nessuno,
o meglio chiedendolo a un robot.
Vengo da un posto che si chiama
Istituto Italiano di Tecnologia,
il quartier generale è a Genova,
ma è composto da un network
sparso in tutta Italia.
Abbiamo un piano scientifico,
una linea guida che ci dice cosa fare.
Fra le cose che dobbiamo fare
c'è la robotica, ma non solo.
Robotica da sola sarebbe un po' riduttivo,
ma noi abbiamo delle connessioni
con dei neuroscienziati che ci dicono
come il cervello risolve certi compiti,
e alcune delle soluzioni
che noi implementiamo nel robot,
in realtà sono derivate dalle cose
che ci dicono i neuroscienziati.
I neuroscienziati, a loro volta, si
connettono con un altro gruppo di persone
che studia le molecole che sono
in grado di agire dentro il cervello,
quindi sviluppano anche nuovi farmaci.
Gli sviluppatori di nuovi farmaci
sfruttano le tecnologie che sono costruite
da un altro gruppo di persone, che
si occupa dei cosiddetti smart materials.
Materiali nanostrutturati, che aiutano a
capire come fare certe molecole,
aiutano a visualizzarle,
a costruirne di nuove,
e poi eventualmente a provarle.
Gli smart materials si connettono però
con aspetti di energia,
quindi ci danno
la possibilità di costruire
batterie più efficienti o sistemi
di produzione energia più efficienti.
Questi servono per la robotica,
perché se devo fare un robot
che va in giro per casa, ho bisogno
che sia autonomo e indipendente.
Il piano scientifico si ispira
tantissimo anche alla natura,
e qui vediamo un esempio di come
i vari livelli e le varie scale,
dall'umanoide alla molecola,
in realtà si connettono
o hanno un parallelo nella natura.
Ѐ un posto dove abbiamo scienziati da
tutto il mondo, 50 paesi diversi.
L'età media, anche se non la potete vedere
da queste foto, è di circa 34 anni,
quindi un posto di giovanissimi.
Io sono un po' più vecchio, purtroppo,
però è un posto interessante.
Questi sono alcuni dei risultati
che abbiamo portato a termine di recente.
Qua si vedono dei video dove facciamo
vedere l'evoluzione della camminata,
dal gattonare, e qualche volta
con qualche fallimento,
come potete vedere in questo video,
al tirarsi in piedi, fare qualche
passo, aiutato da una persona,
e in fondo a fare qualche passo
invece in maniera autonoma.
Questo è il progresso delle cose
che stiamo facendo,
è un pezzettino di quello
che ci serve per arrivare al famoso caffè
che vi dicevo all'inizio.
E con questo vi ringrazio.
(Applausi)
(Musica)